and you would help people get to this
what we call an aha moment they'd find
some sort of
magical value and if you're you're
deeply technical it's a you know a super
grep we're searching we're grepping
across all the different boxes
we're finding that log line we need to
solve our problem
[Music]
jake flomenberg thank you so much for
being on my show 20 minute leaders how
are you
good how are you great where are you
calling from right now i'm calling from
sunny menlo park wonderful so we're very
very close by neighbors but you know
with this kobe situation
uh it's it doesn't matter if we're if
we're two miles apart or a thousand
miles apart
and so either way thank you for being
here very brief overview and then we're
going to spend
we're going to do a deep dive into your
experiences you know worked with you
know so you did
upend and then harvard mba went on to
working with the founders of cloudera as
i think the first business hire
and then running the splunk ui product
which i've used extensively
uh back in you know in my years of
engineering and the idf
and now moved on to uh being a venture
capital partner at excel ventures in
wing
did i get that somewhere right roughly
correct
wonderful jake you know i i still can't
do enough service
to the incredible background that you
have i'd love you to tell me a little
bit more about yourself and then
i'd really love to pick your brain on
these experiences moving from
engineering
working with incredible startups early
on like cloudera and splunk
and then making that smooth transition
into venture capital
and some of your insight into your
investment thesis and how you approach
different opportunities sure so why
don't i give you sort of
a quick rundown on my my background and
a few of the transition points i
went through so so first i actually did
my undergrad at
duke um i did sort of hardware software
and engineering and said to myself
hey how can i try to solve problems in
the real world and
found lockheed martin um and had a lot
of fun
there for a few years had a lot of
impact but it was also a conservative
culture where it's hard for a
21 year old to take on increasing
amounts of responsibility
so i went to business school to retool
and this was in 2008 and i
sort of came upon two trends i was
interested in cloud and data
and cloud it was the early days of
things like amazon web services but they
were
they were a thing at that point and i
said you have to be a big company to
play in this game
and data um and the more i looked at at
this field of big data the more i
realized
hey i think i kind of know a thing or
two about this topic i feel
you know just from reading the trade
rags like i could be useful here
so for for when when summer came around
i
just found every single big data company
i could
um and one of them was called cloudera
they had about 12 employees
oh my god and i called them off and said
hey you know
can can i help literally i called a cold
called the ceo
mike and i spoke to all the founders i
spoke to
the cto armor and i think he actually
thought i was interviewing for a
software engineering job in the
beginning
and so i never had the heart to ask him
how how that interview went i think it
was pretty poor
you know so they said hey come help um
and it was just
you know they were just they were just
engineers and so you know
as we thought about some of the initial
product road maps or
business packagings and things like that
i got to play a really fun role
in in that it was a lot of fun but at
the same time it was
sort of deeply deep technology for
technologists
and i said to myself as i was leaving
business school hey
how do we help mere mortals get some
value out of data
it's great to help people that can write
lots of code but how do we help
let you know less technologically savvy
people
uh benefit from these systems and i
found splunk and i said
wow splunk is sort of this vertically
integrated big data application they
didn't call themselves that but that's
in effect what they were
they were serving mostly assisted men's
or i.t people
right i'm still still deep but but you
know maybe not
quite as as deep and i saw
you know i had a vision i saw the
ability for them to use this platform to
service even less technically
sophisticated people over time um so i
joined splunk and you know i was there
for a couple years right up to their ipo
and looked after pretty much anything
you could touch
um and then right around that time
when splunk was getting ready to go
public i joked that um
the vcs were typing into their linkedin
search box mba plus big data
and i was one of the four hits uh you
know and
in 2012 there were only four hits and so
a large number of people reached out
um and i decided to make the move over
to excel where i'd known some of the
guys i met them
you know through um sitting in a board
meeting uh
at cloudera um and um you know focused a
lot on
on data and analytics and so that depth
of
sort of knowledge and first-hand
experience really enabled me to focus on
a
domain uh or or focus area and which is
what i did when i started at excel i was
there for about
six years and then i came over to wing
and at wing our focus is really trying
to just
build uh help entrepreneurs on that
journey from zero to product market fit
and beyond and so almost putting on
my product monitor hat and saying hey i
want to do one thing really well
there's lots of ways as investors to to
make money with you know consumer funds
and growth funds and
china and india strategies but let's
let's build a product
us as a vc firm around one thing which
is helping
enterprise b2b entrepreneurs
on that initial journey wow okay i don't
even know where to begin i want to go
back to
to cloudera and and splunk because those
two are those two are incredible
incredible companies
you know really like innovators in in
the field that i'm very passionate about
and you know splunk how what was it like
going into a company that has product
market fit with a certain demographic so
right you know sysadmins and people who
are
you know still you know there might not
be necessarily the engineers of the
company but they but they're
very tech savvy today splunk services
you know
any person who's who's able to just you
know to look at graphs and and just
connect the dots right
and so so what is that like coming into
a company and thinking of this vision
and seeing
a product that right now serves a
certain demographic but trying to
extrapolate it on to
you know a larger market yeah i can't
take
you know too much credit here but i can
certainly describe the thought process
going on as a modern company
and you know it's roughly as follows
people
initially at the time they actually
bought splunk for an i.t use case today
if you look at their financials you
might see it's actually a little bit
more slanted to security
in many cases but but back then it was
it was mostly i.t
um and you would help people get to this
what we call an
aha moment they'd find some sort of
magical value and if you're you're
deeply technical it's a
you know a super grep we're searching
we're grepping across all the different
boxes
we're finding that log line we need to
solve our problem right and if you
do that you know 100 times faster and
splunk then logging onto each box you're
very happy
and most people actually did that with
the free product with a free trial or a
free download
and see they were very excited by the
time a sales person actually contacted
them
say like you know what you want to pay
for this um
is that all is that is that generally
the case that you know
so obviously this idea of the freemium
model is that you
you try to get your users to an aha
moment
when the as they're just you know
risk-free taking
a a stab at this software and then when
the sales person comes around it's easy
but is is that
that sounds like very something very
difficult to do right for any company
look i think you have
one i think splunk was one of the
pioneers in the true enterprise space
that sort of
easy use quick value is something that's
now become the norm the consumerization
of enterprise that wasn't you know that
wasn't the tagline
back when splunk got started and there
they made a bunch of very thoughtful
product and pricing decisions but they
also you know they had a great market
they just had
this opportunity where you could make in
the moment of truth when the pager goes
off you could help someone
um if you're building a payroll system
you can delight them but you can't
you can't make them say aha and you know
in quite the same way
uh for the most part right it just sort
of depends what space you're in and so
you help them
solve an acute problem in a moment of
need
um and you know off the back of that you
were able to build a relationship you
were
able to you know eventually have a
financial transaction that happens
and then the way to think about serving
other users
is really to say hey you've put in x
data
what if you put in you know 1.25 x data
just 25 more data and now you can enable
use case y
right and so that's what security was
which was the clear second use case we
have to build more
content for the security practitioners
some of them are very sophisticating
code and write
python and understand the splunk search
language others need
they need charts they need dashboards to
do their job and so
we'll build those canonical dashboards
um you'll pay us for those you'll pay us
to put more
you know data into splunk and now we
serve uh service the second use case and
then
so on and so forth and i think within it
and
securities bunk has done a phenomenal
job and we'll continue building
uh content to service uh many many other
markets
over time so now you're moving on to to
wing vc and over there you're mentioning
that
your focus is on helping entrepreneurs
get their
b2b sas platform to to that product
market fit and beyond right from the
very early stages
so what are some of the things that
you're observing as you're going through
this journey
what what are some of you know the the
you know the common challenges that
you're observing
because you're really seeing
entrepreneurs very very early on
as they might have an mvp and they're
trying to get these enterprises to buy
into it
it doesn't sound very easy to me yeah
well i mean so
you know we have a tendency to work with
deep technological founders who have
an insight about a particular domain
area and this might be
core i.t or it might be in the real
world i spend a lot of time looking at
things
like computer vision these days and i
have to tell you that there's going to
be some value in
core enterprise but a lot of the value
of these systems is
out in the real world right where you
can see things and
and react um and you know
[Music]
some struggling there's a lot of
struggles that these entrepreneurs go
through hiring the right people is
certainly a struggle
most people don't struggle all that much
in hiring the the tech talent on in the
early days
but that initial business model that
initial
go to market strategy sometimes that's
something that the entrepreneur has done
before often this is a new domain or
that might be completely foreign to them
and so that's an area
where we really try to roll up our
sleeves and
not do but help and support right and
say here's an example
of uh ahead of sales for a company in
adjacent space that's
you know at public company scale you're
never going to hire them but maybe
they're great at
you know a great advisor here's an
example of the marketing candidate
um you're going to want in another year
um
right and to try to surround them with
people and
and sort of thought partners that they
can use to continually evolve their
thinking
and just encouraging people to take that
experimental mindset
sometimes people treat go to market like
this black box where we hire a vp of
sales spend
a couple million dollars and see what
happens and you know it's
it's two years in and and a lot of money
wasted before you can make any changes
interesting and so that that's where
the area for sure where we sort of most
repetitively and deeply engaged
it's not very common for institutional
vcs to come in
that early on right i mean i know a lot
of a lot of vcs like to join and once
you have
some some some great returns and you
have a good arr and you're
and you're ready to take your series
your series a and grow
it it depends um you know you should
check out the wing.dc blog if you want
to see
some pretty deep analysis by my partner
peter that really unpacks those trends
um what i'd say is as follows wing
invests in
in sort of three buckets uh the
experimental seed bucket which is
we'll call it a two million dollar check
maybe there's some deep technological
risk
does can you even build this does this
market even exist
right um we invest in this round we call
the power seed
um which is you know maybe it's a four
to six million dollar financing it takes
a long time to build deep enterprise
tech
and some people are marketing these
things as seed extensions or c2s which
in my humble opinion is not great
marketing someone says oh i've raised my
seat extension and i say
i'm sorry for your loss you know i think
we could do better in branding these
things
and then the classic series a which you
know fluctuates a bit it you know sort
of ramped up really high in 2019 maybe
this is that
eight to 15 million dollar check size
and wing actually aspires to invest
across this entire spectrum wonderful um
and i think you see some some other some
large firms they sort of dabble
um they'll play in this in this sort of
experimental seed or power seed
phase certainly in light of kovid we've
seen some people
redouble their efforts a little bit
there but you're right a lot of people
are waiting for the series a
and 82 percent of the series a's these
days have
you are post revenue um and if you look
at the valuations
what are the series a's these are the
series b's from a decade ago
yeah is basically what they are and so
this this
power seed phase where you know we have
a little bit of product
we we have probably we're still
pre-revenue in many cases
um we've engaged with the customers um
meaningfully that's an area that we feel
really well equip
equipped to play we're happy to roll up
our sleeves we're happy to talk to those
customers
and figure things out um with the
entrepreneur
there's some firms that will participate
and engage in such a process and
there's there's many others that will
say hey you know let's just wait until
it's obvious
right so investing in deep technology
it's a different type of investment than
then you know
going mainly off of you know the market
and the and you know
just the financials you're actually
looking sometimes at founders who are
who are really you know
they they think that they have they've
understood their their niche
better than others and they are able to
develop something that is cutting edge
and that is really going to to innovate
on their domain they're not just going
and trying to to take a similar
technology that exists and implement it
into another market
how do you go even about doing proper
due diligence on that and how do you
as a venture capital firm support
entrepreneurs who are dedicated to deep
technology
because innately they're spending you
know years of research
on these things and then you have to
come in and you have to
determine within a matter of days or
weeks whether this is something that you
believe in
yeah you know it's it that the way you
describe it
makes it sound hard on the other end
i don't know how hard it is right so i
have i have enough of a technical
background that
i can't go toe-to-toe with these
entrepreneurs maybe i can pretend for
some period of time but
i can i can determine whether or not
something is real whether it's you know
is this bs or is this
is this real um and then if it's real
you know
we do the following one we're going to
find the foremost
domain authority to help validate you
know the elements of risk that we see
in the technology whether that's the
computer vision or the ai or the
containers or
you know whatever it happens to be um
and then
you know depending on the state of the
product we're going to go out and talk
to
the customers and understand what their
perception is what it is that they have
and haven't been able to
validate what it is that they they need
how it is that they're going to procure
um and then we sort of line everything
up and say all right
here's you know here's the scorecard
here's the the risks and opportunities
we see
um does this make sense and do we think
that this entrepreneur is uniquely
capable of navigating
uh through this environment wow very
very cool and
you know you it really sounds like a lot
of the experiences that you've had
leading up to the venture capital world
have really you know come together to
give you this balanced
and well-rounded insight into into the
different things that you're doing do
you feel and i'm now i'm speaking as a
young entrepreneur and you know a lot of
my friends who are who are following
this they're also young engineers young
entrepreneurs
perhaps out of 8 200 in israel or
perhaps out of stanford or mit here in
the us
and now my question is you've had a lot
yeah a variety of different experiences
both in engineering and then product
management and business
do you think there are some there are
some experiences that are
more that were more worthy of your time
than others that
you know because in my generation we
have to make a lot of decisions all the
time
which companies do we go to what fields
do we study how long do i want to be an
engineer before i make my transition to
product management
just as an example it's something that
i'm grappling with and a lot of my
friends are grappling with
which experiences do you think really
tipped
then it you know moved the needle for
you well look it it all depends
what you want to accomplish in in your
career and i'll make
two points one it's
almost impossible to become more
technical over time once you leave the
engineering ranks
you've left the engineering ranks most
people don't circle back
right um and so people often rush to
get on with it or become a product
manager whatever that is but
for the most part that's a one-way trip
so you know choose your decision path
wisely
and know that you know maybe 20 30 years
ago
people didn't really empower
technical ics individual contributors in
the same way that they
do today and you sort of you had to
become at least a manager right or your
paycheck wasn't getting any bigger
um and companies like google and others
have done a great job really saying hey
there's a path
uh to become you know a level eight or
whatever it is
i see and get rewarded for it so like
that that's a viable career career
strategy
actually one of the most one of the most
incredible innovative things that i've
observed in the israeli military is this
is this exact same idea that you know
and then if the israeli military was all
it's known that you want to go higher
you have to become an
officer and you have to grow your ranks
and get your different ranks or whatever
and all of a sudden in in the
intelligence unit they're saying uh-uh
we actually have a new method
you can you don't have to be an officer
you can be a professional
technologist and get paid just as much
and
actually they get paid more than the
officers and they become this
professional persona
yeah well i mean like if you think about
it you know some engineers are not the
you know the most gregarious people in
the world some of them love to manage
love to talk to people there's others
that don't they're
two orthogonal skill sets and why you
would forcibly lump them together
um you know creates
a sub-optimal allocation of talent
resources 100
100 um so so one like don't rush to
become less technical
two i think being a ceo or
being a product manager is the closest
that you can get to possibly
um to preparing yourself for a career in
venture
and you know what i mean by that is
simply that these people sit at the
intersection of business and technology
they're they're not just writing the
code and
they're not just selling it um and that
ability to sit on both sides of the
fence is
is very important in evaluating a
business i wish it was just build
the right technology or the best
technology and that wins that's
decidedly not the case in in the real
world so you really need
both perspectives and i joke with with
product managers that
venture capital is sort of like meta
product management in some sense you
don't
you don't get to write any of the specs
you don't get to manage the
ceos in the same way but at a different
level that is
sort of how i think about the space i
haven't thought about this
this transition and and that the product
management
side has such a big influence on on you
know on the venture capital work
and i don't believe that most venture
capitalists
have had a much product management
experience i know some of them had
a lot of them come from financial
backgrounds right from finance and
and or or potentially ceo but but this
is something that
is it's very interesting to me well you
know particularly at the early stage of
enterprise b2b companies i think it's a
really relevant background to have
definitely you're out raising your
growth capital round it can still be
interesting but there's a lot of people
that
you know are going to be a lot more
facile with with the metrics and
the spreadsheets but in that early days
having
you know a support system a thought
partner um
to help navigate some of those issues on
the product side i think can be
immensely valuable right and you know
hopefully some of the entrepreneurs i
work with have found that to be the case
jake this was so enjoyable and time just
goes by way too quickly on on this show
i always joke that i wish i called it 30
minute leaders instead of 20 minute
leaders
but now i'm stuck with the name so i
have to hold on to 20 minutes but before
we go i have to ask you for three words
that you would use to describe yourself
three words that describe myself um
i'm diligent i i think i i try to work
hard
i'm dependable you know i'm there when
uh
i'm needed and i guess that's not
something that you take for granted
dependable it's uh something that i've
learned i'm very good times and bad
times there's uh
there's a lot of stress as as being an
entrepreneur and
you you need uh you need folks that are
going to show up
when you need it you know and also i
have to go for the alliteration so
probably d
i'm willing to get i'm willing to go
deep to really understand
uh what it is that people are building
and trying to accomplish so
there you go i love it so dependent
diligent and deep
jake thank you very very much it was
wonderful i learned so much
i really appreciate it i really
appreciate you taking the time to do
this
absolutely thanks so much for doing it
take care bye